E aí
[Aplausos]
[Música]
e vocês têm ideia da importância do
Jurassic Park na história do cinema
Então deixa eu contar aqui para mim
história ele também teve uma importância
gigantesca quando eu tinha 17 anos em
1993 eu fui no cinema assisti esse filme
e ver pela primeira vez aqueles
dinossauros não a tela de cinema
convincentes e vivos por uma coisa de me
arrepiar me arrepia até hoje eu percebi
naquele momento que qualquer história
que você quisesse contar agora podia ser
contada e isso e a mover a minha vida
pelos próximos quase 20 anos naquele
momento eu decidi que eu queria fazer
computação gráfica eu decidi que a
melhor escola que existe era no Canadá e
eu me mudei para lá com 23 anos para
estudar animação e efeitos especiais
depois de um ano é estudando eu tive uma
oportunidade de me juntar um estúdio de
animação para desenhos animados fizeram
eu vi
e eu fui crescendo e me desenvolvendo
nessa carreira depois de uns oito anos
que eu tava no Canadá eu fiz uma
entrevista com a lucasfilm para um
trabalho de um estúdio que eles estavam
abrindo depois de uns 3 meses me ligaram
de novo me chamando para uma segunda
entrevista não Sky Walker Reich em São
Francisco deixa eu repetir no Sky Walker
Green São Francisco só entrar naquele
lugar para mim já tinha um significado
que valia não precisava nem do trabalho
depois Você entrava no estúdio que era
espalhado numa fazenda aonde tinha o
casas que representavam cada uma das
divisões uma casa era o Sky Walker sound
que ganhou quase todos os óscares de som
até hoje as outras casas eram uma ao
escritório do George Lucas a biblioteca
no lugar era como se estivesse entrando
no filme do Harry Potter de um vitrines
espalhadas eu lembro de um objeto que
era o laço de Nina Jones estava ali
e a pessoas naquele lugar estavam
literalmente escrevendo a história do
cinema
a chegar perto daquele nível de
profissional para mim já era Fantástico
eles me convidaram para me juntar ao
time que estava abrindo o estúdio de
Cingapura
e para mim era uma segunda Mudança Já
estava bem adaptado ao Canadá mas eu
achei bastante interessante como mais um
desafio e como de uma certa forma mais
um degrau em direção ao meu sonho de
fazer aqueles filmes que eu queria tanto
fazer
é que eu tava me mudando de país pela
segunda vez ainda mora na Ásia de
Cingapura eu não sabia onde ficava no
mapa mas eu aceitei o desafio e em
Cingapura eu fui viver os maiores
desafios que eu já tinha vivido até
então na minha carreira você tem ideia
do que quer trabalhar com 48
nacionalidades diferentes de pessoas
pessoas que falam a mesma língua em
inglês mas ao mesmo tempo não tem a
mesma percepção do que está sendo falado
Você perguntava uma coisa por exemplo
por uma pessoa e falava você consegue me
entregar isso na sexta-feira
bom e você percebia que a resposta era
sempre sim mas as pessoas não entregavam
na sexta-feira porque várias culturas
diferentes tinha um problema muito
grande em falar não você aprende a fazer
a pergunta certa se você perguntasse
para mesma pessoa quando você consegue
me entregar isso a resposta virá que era
na quarta-feira seguinte a gente foi
aprendendo aos poucos em como fazer essa
pergunta certa um dia a gente ficou
sabendo que o George Lucas estava vindo
visitar o estúdio vamos instruídos de
que você não poderia nem falar com ele
nem tirar foto porque já tinham 200
pessoas no estúdio se todo mundo fosse
tirar foto com ele ele praticamente não
conseguiria andar eu também não era
diferente queria falar com George Lucas
eu decidi fazer uma armadilha eu tinha
acabado de terminar um episódio que isso
acontecia na neve no planeta que chamava
Orto plutonia que o próprio George Lucas
tinha criado e eu sabia que ele ainda
não tinha visto nenhuma imagem nesse
planeta o desafio de fazer esse planta
na Neve era enorme porque as cenas são
muito contadas no com efeitos especiais
um desenho animado com efeitos em quase
todas as cenas Como foi esse planeta era
uma coisa muito difícil de ser executada
quando George Lucas ia passar pela minha
mesa eu peguei a minha cena predileta de
outro plutônio Aí deixei rodando em loop
na minha senha no meu computador e dão
certo quando ele passou ele sentou na
minha mesa e eu pude mostrar para George
Lucas A primeira imagem que ele viu
daquele planeta que ele mesmo tinha
criado era Fantástico tá do lado de uma
pessoa que foi tão importante para a
história do entretenimento como um todo
depois de um tempo eu recebi uma
proposta de fazer
é de animação e Madrid
e eu decidi mais uma vez aceitar um
desafio Eu me mudei para Madrid um de a
língua passava a ser de uma certa forma
uma barreira apesar de todo o Brasil era
achar que a gente fala espanhol eu fui
aprender que a gente não fala espanhol
eu fazer as minhas reuniões e depois das
reuniões vai fazer a revisões das
reuniões com meu chefe em inglês para
ter certeza que os meus objetivos
estavam corretos e que eu tava fazendo a
coisa certa
e eu tava gostando muito de morar na
Europa e o contrato de Madrid era
temporário então comecei a pensar qual
que ia ser a próxima coisa qual que era
o meu próximo passo para chegar no lugar
onde eu queria
bom e vamos deixar um rap de efeitos
muito grande então eu fui para Londres
fazer algumas entrevistas e conhecer
alguns estúdios e Recebi uma proposta de
um dos estúdios para mim juntar o time e
fazemos filmes que eu tanto sonhava
fazer os grandes efeitos de Hollywood a
em Londres também tinha uma questão da
Cultura Inglesa o jeito duro e direto de
ser que eu acho que eu até anotei de uma
certa forma aí hoje eu gosto muito
Já fiz vários filmes em Londres vários
blockbusters entre eles Harry Potter
Tour Godzilla um dos filmes que mais me
mexeu comigo foi Harry Potter porque ele
criou não só uma cultura e uma geração
que cresceu vendo esse filme como ele
criou a indústria em si em Londres
e o estúdio foi de 400 para mil e
duzentas pessoas no período que eu tava
lá a gente passou de um para três países
e ganhamos um Oscar pelo filme A Origem
inception que foi uma vitória Grande
para todos estúdio quando chegaram as
estatuetas eu tive a chance de segurar
uma estatueta do Oscar ali você tinha
certeza segurando uma estatueta de que
você tá no topo do mundo e que você
tinha chegado lá
e depois de um tempo decide voltar para
o Brasil com a minha filha de dois anos
e minha esposa a gente fez mais essa
mudança o que eu não esperava é que eu
tinha que me adaptar de novo ao Brasil
eu me senti um estrangeiro no meu
próprio país no Brasil você esquece o
que que era a desigualdade social EA
violência urbana que a gente sofre aqui
por todos os dias você não tem mais um
exército para fazer os filmes Mas
algumas pessoas grandes desafios
engraçado pensar que em Londres para mim
era o último degrau que eu achava que eu
tinha subido e hoje olhando eu vejo que
o Brasil ainda estavam degrau acima
e no Brasil eu fui conhecer talentos
enormes que podem sim concorrer com a o
talento internacional o poder de se
adaptar a realidade EA criatividade do
brasileiro é são Monstros tem uma
história do Fernando Meirelles quando
Spielberg veio e perguntou para ele como
que tinha sido feita a cena da galinha
da entrada do Cidade de Deus é uma cena
linda onde a galinha Sai de cima do
morro desce pelo meio da favela e acaba
no meio da rua passando por baixo no
camburão super emocionante ele queria
saber quais foram as técnicas que foi 3D
como é que eles conseguiram filmar
Aquela galinha e o Fernando falou
e o meu fotógrafo amarrou uma lente uma
câmera 16mm no cabo de uma vassoura e
ele saiu correndo atrás da galinha
é a nova ordem mundial é fazer mais com
menos e nisso brasileiro é muito bom
e depois de um tempo aqui eu fui
convidado de novo para ir para Londres
trabalhar no filme do Aladdin eu cheguei
no estúdio e alguns momentos depois fui
chamado para uma reunião em que me
falaram que o time que tava fazendo o
último Jurassic world' reino ameaçado
tava com dificuldades e precisava de
ajuda não tinha nada que eu queria ouvir
mais do que aquilo
e eu fui para sala do Jurassic minha
pele arrepiada de ver aqueles
dinossauros em todas as telas
e de uma certa forma ali eu tava
realizando aquele sonho matando o último
dinossauro da Ilha de no bar pensando
muito no até DX eu vendo com a mensagem
que podia passar para as outras pessoas
contando a minha história que parece um
pouco um conto de fadas onde tudo deu
certo
e eu fiquei pensando porque que tinha
essa história que parecia tanto esse
conto de fadas e foi porque eu não me
apeguei as coisas ruins do meu caminho
eu me apeguei as coisas boas é claro que
tiveram momentos de stress tiveram
lugares feios tiveram momentos de
saudade eu mudei de casa 17 vezes em 20
anos ninguém merece né eu tive
apartamentos horríveis e tive
apartamento muito bacanas muitas vezes
eu tive em quieto mas eu usei essa
inquietação para mim colocar no lugar
melhor para mudar para fazer minha vida
chegar num lugar diferente que fosse
melhor da onde do que é onde eu tava se
me perguntassem hoje se eu trocaria
minha escalada para chegar lá em cima
vou pegar o elevador e chegar mais
rápido eu diria que não eu não trocaria
por que o caminho que teve o valor maior
do que o objetivo final
E se eu posso deixar três mensagens do
que deu certo para mim uma é que eu fiz
o melhor em todos os lugares que eu
passei e se você fizer o melhor em todos
os lugares que você for e se passa seu
cartão de visita e às vezes até a sua
passagem para o próximo passo
e a segunda é Celebrar cada momento e
cada pequena Vitória e lembrar desses
momentos todo mundo passa por coisas
ruins e terceiro usar o sentimento que
te incomodam para te levar para um lugar
melhor obrigado
E aí
[Aplausos]